and again start from the 10 we're going
to add the hand
so living through get to the black here
[Music]
so which way should is inertia P go over
so if I'm turning them in place I have
to solve them so if I go like this you
see yeah it stopped but if I keep him
going forward now I'm pulling against it
so when I turn I keep him going into
this model but he's never pulling away
from me but he's going forward okay so I
don't want to come here and then turn
you on that leg because that's where
this thing got in the clocks me or stabs
me but I hated you go forward I'm going
to use a spiral to do this
you see these keeps going forward boom
then that is very much like just take me
so use the spider would when he takes
that step all I do is hold the on
position here is inertia makes the ball
here he goes whoa hold it just hold it
here inside
you will lose more of the Kazushi the
further you are from this line or the
less you connect from where you're
touching to the center you understand
these two things so depending on their
skill level those are two things or
they're the same thing okay so when I
come up here on his wrist it's still on
this Center it's still on his Center no
me i affected his Center from where I'm
touching but as your skill level is down
you have moved further from the spine
and you can have what's lacking the
shoulder joint because you didn't carry
tension into there and he starts to turn
on you and here thumbs up lunge but yes
so it's a feeling that you're not that
high
I have to feel that from here I have his
Center no matter where I am in a circle
did I push it on his body boom boom and
again it's relaxed but can you push it
to me no he can't push it okay so we're
here
Oh Center see I'm not grabbing him
pushing whoa and then I use that same
to take that corner out he continues
forward and he lost that is the same
structural tactic of this I keep his
head he said there was going forward
and he fought exactly say copula is
closer guys overhead so around he's
going forward I stay around home hold
the corner if you find I don't know
where this Center is I would recommend
you get closer to the spine come up here
by the elbow whoa I tend to favor the
elbow marshalling anyways I don't favor
the wrist so I'm sure another projection
throw in to watch the difference on your
swing as
oh okay so next the state so I go here
look how far that 10 cotton is okay he
takes that step to things what I am
supposed to have a center connection
Indian but please understand that as
this starts to move and his body starts
to move it starts to change and you guys
don't change
you guys keep with that pressure there
and now when you bring his arm over here
that's not doing anything so that's why
I say it's a feeling you're trying to
maintain a feeling okay and that right
now opens the door for you might have to
do something with the wrist you see if I
feel off a lot of slack here then I
might bring it back into this you see
and then you might but if you stay where
you are right it don't it'll work
you don't you believe that you can find
that Center
so look I'll take it off get up get up
you'll see you see I'll put it on so
that's what I'm using in the arm because
I don't understand how to affect your
Center from wherever he's touching for
wherever I'm touching then too much
slack allows people to turn in your
Kazushi angle you get popped
okay got it so correct this beginner
mistake don't have one connection point
have a feeling that you're keeping as
they are leaving you as they projected
away from me okay
try so what what happens when I have his
Center is he has not every angle as
possible
do you understand that not every angle
is possible
so like he could go out but when when I
have him going around he has to first go
around then he can go out so you you add
you reduce possible angles with center
connection and you reduce more by
harmonizing with his inertia okay and so
what happens when you don't have the
center
all this sloppily arm you give him a lot
of angles
so this better this skill right here
where my god the center combat skill is
key if I let it off you can come at me
if I keep it on this shoulder gets
locked elbow gets long and then his body
was going forward you get that so
through the inertia and then the center
connection I take out the slop out of
the joints and you would use to pivot
around and give me that strike let's now
ask you less of the technique so you
just walk in this show boom just because
you have
[Music]
you